hello same phone it is glad to be back
in Minnesota even I love you back that's
why I came here princesita elbow
connector can I can I just say that that
when we get off the plane secretary Foxx
who is from North Carolina turn to me
and he said this is the coldest I've
ever been in my life now we were only
out there for like a minute which goes
to show how soft these folks from North
Carolina or when it comes to the low
I on the other hand from Chicago I've
got those stairs I was like this is this
Bobby this is great in February in
Minnesota can't be cannot beat it ah in
addition to secretary Foxx who I want to
give them a big round of applause for
that introduction
you've got two champions for the people
of Minnesota were here today you got
representative Betty McCollum and
representative Keith Ellison you've got
your mayor chris colon in the house
the new mayor of Minneapolis Betsy
Hodges was here and my great friend who
actually told me I was running for
president before I knew I was running
for president RT Rybak love that man now
I want to thank everybody who showed me
around union depot and gave me a preview
of this new light rail line it is
fantastic and and I also just want to
say even though he's not here today I
want to say to everybody how Michelle
and I have been keeping in our thoughts
and prayers one of the great Americans
that we know as well as a great
Minnesotan Walter Mondale now like
millions of Americans I've spent some
time with Minnesotans lately because i
was watching the olympics minnesota sent
19 athletes to the games not that that's
tied for second most of any state and
they did us all proud it is not shocking
that Minnesotans might be pretty good at
the Winter Olympics
what is particularly interesting is that
once again the tiny town of war road
proved that it really is hockey town USA
thanks to TJ oshie and Gigi Marvin who
you know we're just so proud of and TJ's
shootout performance against the
Russians I must say I enjoyed a lot I
tweeted Adam about it so we've spent
some time over the last few weeks on
hockey but I'm not here to talk about
hockey by the way I cannot play hockey I
I grew up in Hawaii we do not have
hockey but I'm here to talk about what
you're doing in the Twin Cities and and
how you're helping to create new jobs
and new opportunities for every American
we are at a moment when our economy is
growing our businesses have created
about eight and a half million new jobs
in the past four years unemployment is
that the lowest it's been in over five
years in Minnesota it's lower than it's
been in six and a half years
and by the way you've got a great
governor who I served with in the Senate
Mark Dayton who's helping to make that
happen so so in a lot of ways things are
looking up but in some ways the trends
that had been battering middle-class
families for a long time have gotten
even starker because those the topper
doing better than ever while wages and
incomes for a lot of families have
barely budged and too many families are
working harder than ever just to keep up
so as I said at the State of the Union
address a few weeks back our job is to
reverse those trends we've got to build
an economy that works for everybody
we've got to restore opportunity for all
people so that no matter who we are
where you come from what you look like
you can get ahead if you work hard and
you're responsible and so I laid out an
opportunity agenda that has four parts
number one good jobs that pay good wages
and manufacturing and energy and
innovation and infrastructure number two
train folks with the skills they need to
get those good jobs something that your
senator al franken is doing great work
on every single day he cares a lot about
that job training issue
number three guaranteeing every child
has access to a world-class education
and number four making sure that hard
work is rewarded with wages you can live
on and savings you can retire on in
health care you can count on that's what
we're fighting for Minnesota is helping
to lead the way on on these issues your
state legislature is poised to raise
your minimum wage this year in my State
of the Union address I called for a new
women's economic agenda it's actually a
family economic agenda equal pay for
equal work paid sick leave and more and
their leaders in your state legislature
that are working hard at this because
they know when women succeed America
succeeds
so on all these issues we're reaching
out to members of Congress looking to
see if they're willing to work with us
on some of these priorities but what I
also said that the state of the union is
in this year of action whenever I can
partner directly with states or cities
or business leaders or civic leaders to
act on this opportunity agenda I'm going
to go ahead and do it we can't wait
we've got to move we got to get things
going too many families are counting on
so yesterday yesterday I launched new
hubs to attract 21st century
manufacturing jobs to America and today
I'm here to launch a new competition for
21st century infrastructure and the jobs
that come with because any opportunity
agenda begins with creating more good
jobs and one of the fastest and best
ways to create good jobs is by
rebuilding America's infrastructure our
roads our bridges our rails our ports
our airports our schools our power grids
we've got a lot of work to do out there
and we got to put folks to work
one of the most difficult things about
the financial crisis we went through was
the housing bubble bursting and
construction workers were hammered
harder than just about anybody and while
we've cut the unemployment rate for
construction workers almost in half
since 2010 too many are still looking
for jobs at a time when we've got so
much that we could put them to work on
rebuilding we've got ports that aren't
ready for the next generation of super
tankers we've got more than a hundred
thousand bridges that are old enough to
qualify for Medicare we ever everybody
knows and nobody knows better than
Minnesotans when we've gone through a
winter like this roads are wrecked full
of potholes all across the country
now other countries are not waiting to
rebuild their infrastructure they're
trying to out-build us today so they can
out-compete us tomorrow as a percentage
of GDP countries like China Germany
they're spending about twice what we're
spending in order to build
infrastructure because they know that if
they have the fastest trains on the
planet or the highest rated airports or
the busiest most efficient ports that
businesses will go there but we don't
want businesses go there we want them to
come here to Minnesota we wanted to come
here in the United States of America and
that means the best airports and the
best rows the best trains should be
right here in America at a time when
companies are saying they intend to hire
more people this year we need to make
that decision easier for and we can
create jobs at the same time rebuilding
our transportation systems our power
grids our communications networks all
the things that commerce relies on and
that helped get workers to those jobs so
the bottom line is there's work to be
done workers ready to do it rebuilding
our infrastructure is vital to business
it creates good-paying jobs that by the
way cannot be outsourced this is one of
Congress's major responsibilities
helping states and cities fund new
infrastructure projects
and the reason part of the reason on
focus on this is Congress has an
important deadline coming up if Congress
doesn't finish a transportation bill by
the end of the summer we could see
construction projects stopping the
tracks machine sitting idle workers off
the job so next week I'm going to send
Congress a budget that funds rebuilding
our transportation infrastructure in a
more responsible way by doing it over
four years which gives cities and states
and private investors the certainty they
need to plan major projects projects
like repairing essential highways and
bridges building new transit systems in
fast-growing cities and communities so
folks who live there can get to work and
school every day and spend less time
sitting in traffic
and we're going to have to construct
smarter more resilient transportation
systems that can withstand the worst
impacts of climate change like bigger
surges of water that we've seen in
recent floods so all told my
transportation budget will support
millions of jobs nationwide and will pay
for these investments in part by
simplifying the tax code we're going to
close wasteful tax loopholes lower tax
rates for businesses that create jobs
here at home stop rewarding companies
for sending jobs to other countries use
the money we save with in this
transition to create good jobs with good
wages rebuilding America it makes sense
it makes sense
now I'll be honest way there are leaders
in both parties who are willing to reach
across the aisle in Congress when it
comes to American infrastructure they
know how important it is and and
infrastructure didn't used to be a
partisan issue and shouldn't be democrat
or republican everybody uses roads
everybody uses ports airports
unfortunately time and again over the
past few years there have been some
Republicans in Congress who refused to
act on common-sense proposals that will
create jobs and grow our economy you
know partly it's not that they're I
guess they don't like rose they just
don't want to pay for them and you know
it doesn't work that way you got to come
up with a way to get these projects
going so while Congress is deciding what
it's going to do next I'm just going to
go ahead and do what I can to create
more good jobs and that's why I came
here to say
because because this this project
symbolizes what's possible union depot
was renovated and expanded with the help
of what we call Tiger grants these are
competitive grants that we created as
part of the Recovery Act also known as
the stimulus which actually worked
despite what everybody claims
so the idea is if a city or state comes
up with a plan to modernize
transportation infrastructure that will
have a significant impact on economic
activity and if they line up other
sources of funding to help pay for it
they can win a tiger grant and the
federal government becomes a partner
with these local communities so far
these grants have given a boost to 270
infrastructure projects across all 50
states and you heard secretary Foxx talk
about these these grants are helping
cities like la and states like North
Carolina and they helped you rebuild
this Depot into a hub that will bring
different modes of transportation
together under one roof instead of
scattered across the city Amtrak's going
to be here the new Metro green line will
be here bus lines
and I just I just had a chance to take a
look at some of those spiffy new trains
they are nice they and their energy
efficient they're going to be reliable
you can get from one downtown to the
other in a little over 30 minutes
instead of when it's snowing being in
traffic for two hours
the trains are made in california which
meant folks were put to work here in the
united states building them and and and
here's here's the best part of it not
not only have you made a more efficient
transportation system cutting down
commutes saving on gas reducing carbon
pollution but this Depot has also helped
to boost economic development in
lowertown st. Paul just across the
street the old downtown post office
building is becoming apartments and
shops all told more than 4,000 jobs were
created for this project and we're
seeing businesses crop up and new
development crop up all along the line
so everybody's women and in part because
of some flexibility that we showed
during the planning process the line is
also going to stop in some poor
neighborhoods that oftentimes had
difficulty getting to the places where
there are jobs
so it's going to help folks who live in
the work hard try get into the middle
class helps them get access get helps
people get access to opportunity that up
until this point you know had a tough
time so we know this works today we're
kicking off the next round of
competition for Tiger grants mayors and
governors City Council's state
legislatures all of you who are watching
here today if you've got a great idea
for your city or your state then let us
know your plan if it will encourage
economic activity and support local
businesses and help put people to work
in your country is interested in
partnering with it and Tiger grants
aren't the only way that we can help
cities like st. Paul and Minneapolis
rebuild their infrastructure you've got
federal funding helped to build the
green line that's going to make it
easier than ever to travel between the
two cities you have more than 5000
construction workers from all over
Minnesota helping to build it nearly 200
police officers trained operators
maintenance workers are being hired and
that's not counting all the jobs that
are being created from the offices and
the apartment buildings that are going
to be built along the line because the
train stopped at neighborhoods that have
access to public transportation those
folks are going to work and all of this
can be duplicated all across the country
but unfortunately funding for these
projects are going to be in jeopardy
unless Congress passes this new
transportation bill so so I want
everybody to understand now the good
news is keith Ellison Betty you know
they're already on board they know this
needs to happen Al Franken
all over some Democrats and Republicans
are already working together to make
sure transportation doesn't funding
doesn't run out and we're seeing some
glimmers of hope because this new round
of Tiger grants was the result of
bipartisan cooperation that's what needs
to happen when we work together but
we're going to need your voices telling
a story around the country about why
this is so important roads and bridges
should not be a partisan issue more
Americans should have access to the kind
of efficient affordable transit you're
going to have with the Green Line
there's no there's no faster way or
better way for Congress to create jobs
right now and to grow our economy right
now and have a positive impact on our
economy for decades that if we start
more projects and finish more projects
like this let's create more good jobs
build smarter schools better airports
faster railways better broadband
networks let's educate our kids and our
workers better let's rebuild an economy
where everybody who's willing to work
hard has a chance to get ahead this is
the beginning not the end we've got a
lot more rail we gotta lay we got a lot
more roads we got to travel let's get
going Minnesota thank you god bless you
god bless the United States in there
you